m
[Musique]
ce mardi 27 février annick girardin
ministre d outre-mer s'est rendu sur les
stands du village réunion salon de
l'agriculture à paris le président du
département série men girl a reçu
accompagné du ministre de l'agriculture
stéphane travert la ministre d outre-mer
a visité plusieurs stands et a salué
l'excellence des produits réunionnais ce
que je viens de visiter comme ça on est
notamment ici à la réunion avec le
président du département
c'est ce que fait de meilleur la réunion
est-ce que quelquefois fait de meilleurs
lots trouvères et quand on voit à
l'excellence de ses produits
la recherche qui vient d arrêt derrière
l'application toujours pour aller vers
l'excellence
on peut plus dire bravo la ministre a
annoncé vouloir faire la promotion des
produits réunionnais des produits qui
selon elle ont toute leur place à
matignon et à l'elysée
j'ai trouvé que madame la ministre était
vraiment enchantés de cette visite des
différents stands de la réunion elle a
reconnu la réunion elle est déjà venue
mais là elle a vu à travers ses
différents stands tout à concentrer des
beaux produits de la réunion et j'ai
senti chez elle une écoute attentive une
envie de soutenir le monde agricole
réunionnais donc c'est cela qui que je
retiens une ministre à l'ecoute
disponibles prêts à nous accompagner
dans nos efforts pour développer le
territoire et développer l'agriculture
réunionnaise il ministre à l'écouté des
exposants très fier d'avoir pu présenter
leurs spécialités
on a présenté le poids le mot
le sel à flot de sel le cacao cacao pays
le criollo surtout
donc voilà là aujourd'hui aussi le
géranium le géranium me rosa voilà c'est
très bien au moins là on voit que à
sainté reste bas le trou mer et pour
nous mais on est content parce qu'on a
plus là on a plus la faible ou déguster
notre hôte et de la réunion ne l'était
français alors que je lui ai parlé bête
de la rose bonbon qu'elle avait déjà eu
en cadeau quand elle était venue à la
réunion
et là je lui ai offert donc très en
forme lors quitté de la réunion en lui
disant voilà vous sauvez les deux les
deux auteurs la réunion la ministre d
outre-mer annick girardin se rend visite
à la réunion au mois d'avril
[Musique]